Eddie and I had been working for a few
years by now I don't remember which what
number of films we had made by this time
but but it was great knowing that your
brother was gonna call you and say hey
we're gonna be doing this movie Thank
You me the greatest movie was every
movie we've ever done has been the
greatest movie that they would ever see
a hundred years from now he will be
talking about him I have to say it's so
long ago I don't remember much about it
except that it was cold I changed in my
car and they didn't pay me much but I
have to say it was what is still one of
the most meaningful experiences I've
ever had partly because I was really
dirty and cold and I changed in my car
but mostly because of the people that
you see sitting up here and those that
have gone before it was a great
experience I played bill Blakely a
reporter a member of the new world going
back you know you'll see I'm not gonna
tell you because the visuals I remember
pretty good but I was from the modern
world going back into the world that was
fading and I was a little bit of a
go-between between the story the reality
of the story and the audience that we
had all those 37 or depending on whose
story you believe years ago so I'm gonna
I'm gonna be a perforce brief because
everybody's got to get home by midnight
but I also want to say as a member of
the Academy we are very happy to have
you here we're very proud of this place
and of this institution so welcome that
without a doubt one of the most
extraordinary artists of all time for me
that I've worked with in my life it's a
the director photography that changed my
life and with this movie and that's Rae
Villalobos
we call them let me just say we call no
light or smokey one of the James gammon
gave me that name smokey an urban cowboy
he did the filming he'd come back on the
set you couldn't see anything I come
back from lunch like oh my god I'm
shooting I just saw smokey nine but you
get in it you can see anyway working
with these great filmmakers uh I had no
choice but to really step up the game on
this and my approach because very
organic and we just clicked Eddy and Bob
and the actors we were like it was the
best experience ever had as a filmmaker
because there was no studio really you
know they just set us free they go okay
make a film and usually you know you
have the the suits and everybody else
and we only answer to ourselves we'd be
scrambling up a mountain you're younger
than me you Bob and Hetty where's the
Rio Grande I don't know let's look up
here that looks good oh it's backlit
let's do it you know and the crew never
got up to us you know
finally the camera would arrive and you
know and it wasn't no digitally just the
camera I go okay five six let's shoot
great acting you know Eddie gets on a
horse and it comes to you know he's
trying to get away and all of a sudden
the horse goes down
nothing scripted and we're shooting
great great this is great
Bob's and Bob was on the other camera
and I was on the other camera and it was
just really organic some films you're
just lucky it's you know it's supposed
to rain you know it doesn't for us the
Sun comes up it was that type of film
and it was the best experience ever had
because we just did it and we all were
like one Bob said I don't know who's
directing this I said I don't know
either it was
we won't talk about anything we would
just we would just do it it's very
organic and he also had the same thought
of just making a great film and so I
don't know how it got done but I do let
me tell you yeah but no it was just it
was a great experience and all these
people now are my best friends
Eddie and Bob and Bette been telling
everybody so it was a life it's a life
thing you know anyway I hope you enjoyed
the film I tried to make it is real I
try to make it look like it wasn't lit
because of the time you know I meant
that I think it was a thing on the train
somebody says oh that was great you shot
that you didn't need any lights huh I
said oh thank you very much we had a big
generator and everything and your
lighting and you trying to make it look
natural I'm trying to set the tone for
these great actors anyway I hope you
enjoy the film and I'm happy to see my
friends again